c'est en janvier 2017 que catherine
laborde quitter la présentation de la
météo de tf1 après 28 ans de bons et
loyaux services
un métier dans lequel elle s'invitait
chaque soir dans le salon des français
je pars avec nous avec le froid avec le
teint unifié avec tous ces souvenirs
très vite elle avait fait savoir que
c'est en raison de sa santé qu'elle
avait dû raccrocher les gants
atteinte de la maladie accords de lévis
une pathologie entre parkinson et
alzheimer catherine laborde s'était
rendu sur le plateau de btp pour nous
donner de ses nouvelles
est-ce que vous mesurez le cadeau que
vous faites là ce soir de de m'avoir
invité dans un moment extrêmement
émouvant hier soir c'est dans sept à
huit sur tf1 que catherine laborde était
invité à parler de sa maladie une
maladie aux symptômes très pesant on
sait plus on est un type qui en est elle
a aussi évoqué le soutien très puissant
de son mari qui se bat à ses côtés
comment est-ce qu'il connait mais le
mieux sur méme an plus tôt quand même
plutôt qu'en mai dans si elle a pris la
décision de quitter la météo il ya trois
ans son envie de s'adresser aux français
n'a pourtant pas disparu des français
qu'elle remercie pour leur soutien
sacré très plaisir un visage que les
téléspectateurs n'oublie pas et qui
reste toujours optimiste malgré les
épreuves
[Musique]
très bon porte clés hier dans cette
année catherine j'aimerais vraiment
qu'ils viennent nous voir aussi que je
fasse en énorme bisou parce que je laime
fort oui une maladie qui n'a été
découvert qu'en 1990 ce qui est très
compliqué neurodégénératives ou l'avait
dit mais moi ce qui m'a fasciné c'est
malgré la douleur malgré la maladie le
sourire la leur dans les cieux la la
c'est une lumière ses moyens c'est un
soleil elle m'a illuminé pendant
portrait il faut souligner le travail
d'audrey crespo-mara parce que c'est
très compliqué ce type d'interview faut
pas non plus tomber dans le pathos faut
pas aller chercher les larmes pour les
larmes etc
elle était sur le fil tout le temps et
je les trouvais vraiment aller à la
juste mesure de cette interview c'est ça
qui est souvent parce que hier manger
vous pourrez regarder aussi et alors
c'est bizarre ce que je viens mais moi
elle m'a donné le sourire
elle est comme la météo elle et s'est
elle fait plaisir aux français elle est
vraie elle est nature et avec cette
tristesse moi elle m'a donné le sourire
on est d'accord sur les réseaux sociaux
tout le monde était très ému mais moi
quand j'ai regardé j'ai dû me tue la
larme à l'oeil parce que c'est une femme
qui a été quand même dans notre
quotidien quand on regarde la météo et
donc on aime beaucoup catherine laborde
et d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup de monde
qui ont regardé sur l'interview parce
que c'était face à roland garros donc au
reei c'était la concurrence était
compliqué pourtant il ya eu un pic
pendant l'interview de catherine laborde
elle est revenue sur sa maladie une
pathologie qui la prive de plus en plus
de sa mémoire et son autonomie regarder
quels sont vos symptômes aujourd'hui
d'abord j'ai peur de mémoire sans arrêt
là je viens de vous parler je sais plus
ce que j'avais digne de mer plutôt on
sait plus où on est on sait plus qui on
est les mets symptômes aujourd'hui c'est
un gamin qui est tout à fait récent
c'est que je ne sais plus quand je suis
dans le noir si je suis en haut en bas
c'est l'impression d'être dans une sorte
de machine comme ça a secoué et je sais
pas trop je suis qui je suis ça m'arrive
de perdre l'équilibré
ce mal est souvent souvent souvent ces
deux tribus chez je n'ai pas les moyens
c'est trop cher fois que je vais vous
dire quelque chose qui auquel je tiens à
coeur mais ça s'échappe ça c'est pas
grave on va vous en faites pas qu'après
à ct c'est vrai que catherine laborde
jaune ajoute revend un extrait ces cas
là elle a également évoqué la
bienveillance à son égard depuis
l'annnonce de sa maladie de tout le
monde
meriem vous connaissez catherine laborde
et lui c'est un exemple c'est moi j'ai
adoré j'avais les larmes aux yeux hier
franchement ça m'a fait trop mal au
coeur parce que quand j'étais jeune je
disais tout le temps il ya tellement de
problèmes dans la vie qu'on va grandir
et on j'aimerais bien avoir l'alzheimer
pour oublier plein de trucs mais là hier
quand j'ai regardé j'avais vraiment mais
nous avons quand même parce qu'elle nous
a redonné l'espoir en fait
regardez regardez dernière c'est un
outil qui va l'emporter je pense à un
moment ou un autre
c'est dommage j'aurais bien aimé que ça
dure encore longtemps mais les gens ne
vous oublie pas oui c'est ce qu'on est
quelques fois ça me fait très plaisir
qu'est ce que vous disent les gens
utilisent soigner vos biens surtout
soigner vous a surtout alors ce qu'il
paraît vraiment quelque chose d'anodin
tout le monde y est bonne bonne bonne
santé là ça prend une dimension très
vrai très très intense très réel il faut
être vivant il faut être dans le
mouvement avis
et ça se fait pas tout seul mais mais la
vie continue
[Applaudissements]